Ryan it's absolutely important to hear
all of the arguments in these types of
issues especially picking up on
Kathleen's question to how they dovetail
with one another those who are in the
region again with regard to the yamen a
project we don't have a pre-established
agenda for the Yamuna River that we're
bringing there we're interested in
bringing together people involved in the
region who live in the region and who
have the recess resources for thinking
about it so this whole project is
oriented towards on the ground voice
people at the table so I guess my
response would be that quite often those
very people that you mentioned who are
employed with regard to coal mining
activity very seldom do they have a
voice in the overarching project of
mountaintop removal itself the only way
they can come into it is by joining some
either environmental resistance group or
some group that's trying to explore what
this is about there's there's rarely an
opportunity for someone who's say in a
neutral perspective someone who hasn't
made a decision yet how they feel about
a mountaintop removal there's very
little settings in which they can begin
to explore what their role or what
they're on the ground activity have what
effect it has in relationship to this
project so the religion and ecology
project is trying to develop forums in
which different voices can can come
together certainly those with regard to
employment in the region are crucial but
again my response to a Kathleen I would
repeat it that it's not the stopping of
coal mining in the region it's the
exploration of how many jobs are really
related to mountaintop removal are there
other ways of getting coal and what what
are the environmental consequences of
both of those types of coal mining